in Greece today most people have a sad
story to tell about the financial crisis
but not these two you cannot stay and
crying all the time you have to to be a
little optimistic because life is now
everybody was like you are crazy what
are you talking about to create
something now indecent now that's the
best moment because now during crisis
this is your point this is about the
bottom line now we can go up create
something what they achieved has its
roots in this tree via meriki our medic
is a theory that can survive under very
difficult circumstances in a salty water
and climbing near the sea every person
that knows our miracle tree he usually
has an experience and that tree an
experience of rest of calm of sleep or
of cool thoughts in the Greek summer and
all those in the Greek summer Christine
and konstantinos moved from pricey
Athens to nafplio a seaport and popular
tourist destination 140 kilometers away
in March 2016 they opened a t-shirt shop
and named it Amory key we didn't have
anything to do with desserts with brands
with a design communication with grant
identity the founders started up without
a bank loan or money from their family
this is all uncharted territory for the
couple who both trained in other fields
I started civil engineer I went then to
Seattle to inverse the Washington for a
master's degree and you and I studied
the economical in the technology
institution of Thessaloniki my studies
are good not very not many many studies
and I used to work in a bank and I so
many things things involving people in
dire financial straits Christina became
disillusioned with the conventional
banking sector as did many of the
individuals running the companies they
now supply with orders the owners of
this print shop only recently started up
their business
we started off with no money at all you
don't need them to start to get started
maybe you needed to develop okay but
after you've started money comes no
usually hurts a lot we searched a lot as
in every part it was very difficult to
find the a very good people to their job
but especially to trust us because we
didn't have an experience but then we
found passing this team and step by step
we create a relationship between us for
this project they've produced about
2,000 t-shirts so far here's where the
labels are made this company creates a
huge range of product tags to help
establish a brand's identity vital for
the many new firms founded since the
financial crisis to make something
special you have to put your soul that's
the main thing and when you put your
soul you put things that you like so for
us when we set for all the parts of the
go over the production line we set for
the best part because we believe that
through time we can create the
circumstances that this product can
survive finding the right design is
critical they only realize this after
they began production so they had to
partner up with an agency doesn't cost
us somehow they weren't the same states
like us they gained their independence
they created something by themselves a
few times before they were open they
were open release two new things they're
currently developing a website with a
database that shows where r muriqui's
customers are located
after only six months their t-shirts can
be found around the world a success
story in the midst of a crisis the
crisis in itself is already related to a
creative process in certain level which
is obviously something very ambiguous to
say because probably you need also
material to actually be creative but
with less material you could be more
creative sometimes I think that's for
what concerns also the identity for I'm
Ricky right now they don't have much
more than their own determination the
money they set aside to start the
business didn't last long so they had to
have faith in themselves we have to have
a vision a personal vision to create
something even to the worst
circumstances we want to show that you
can do something different and you can
move on and you know people just need
this somebody to tell them that you can
do it to see it to your eyes and they
get the energy that is needed to do it
and they will do it this is missing
today
you